so let's pick up again it was only half
an hour ago so probably remember where
we left off we had just put down a
construct Canada construction for 1/16
argument so now what I want to do is I
want to spend maybe just couple of
minutes just remarking on the fact fact
that from a tactical perspective it does
fulfill the sort of all of 16
communication complexity and
verification time and then I want to say
a little bit about the way you analyze
[Music]
let's just do it quickly
mm communication-wise what do we see
well we see a hash function you know
that says sighs Paulina security
parameter so that's definitely within
our budget we see a output of a hash
function easy right so so far we are
still within budget we see randomness we
said that's Pauly Lochte okay and then
we see answers to the queries okay so
the complexity the communication
complexity of this particular
construction depends on the query
complexity of your PCP so if your PCP
will have you know crappy communication
complexity then you won't inherit the
crappiness over here conversely if you
achieve pretty good for the complexity
for example poly locti then you know
we're still within budget here okay what
else do we have
you have the authentication paths okay
so you have an additional dependence
here the path is you know as long as the
path is and how long is it well in a
Merkle tree the length of the path will
be logarithmic in the number of things
number of leaves right so here we have a
dependency on the length of the proof
okay but because the proof is polynomial
okay a the depth of an Oracle tree built
over it will be logarithmic in T okay so
here you will have locti long paths each
element in the path is a digest so an
output of the hash function so that's
been a poly Kay so overall here we see
that we are achieving our goal of poly
in a security parameter and log T okay
so that's one aspect now let's look at
the time complexity of the constructed
prover and constructed verifier over
here a well the argument approver is
running the PCP prover okay so you
better make sure that that thing runs
efficiently okay and then you're
building a miracle tree over the proof
this is a linear time visit you know
when you build a miracle tree the number
of leaves and a miracle tree is linear
in the number of lis
so the number of nodes in the Merkle
tree remember of hashing vocations is
linear a number of leaves okay so you
will be doing all of size of Pi
invocations of the hash function okay so
the hash function will take you your
poly K right so these are the two
dominating factors okay and really you
know you should think about this is the
bigger dominating one right so here once
you have the proof you're just basically
hashing it down to a root okay the point
is that overall here
I didn't really say that but you know
the point is that we have an efficient
honest prover okay on the very fire side
what is the very far doing its sampling
a hash function that ought to be easy
samples around honest probably easier
checking the paths so the verifier does
have a dependence on the proof length
but it's logarithmic right so they have
some poly K log T cost here to check all
the paths and then you're just running
the verifier you know sort of you're
really like natively plain text in some
plain text computation for the PCP so if
this one is fast then so will this be
okay and we started with a PCP where the
very far is faster by the way this
construction is of course interesting
even for PCP is where the verifier is
not fast right because you will still
get communication complexity so in
general there's a wide range of settings
of parameters where if you plug in a PCP
into this construction we'll get
something interesting in particular it
is interesting for these settings of
parameters but you don't take them
religiously it's like just I wrote this
down so that they match up with these
yeah fine any questions about the
efficiency aspects of this construction
okay the only reason why we kind of went
through it explicitly just sort of I
think the construction of
I will remark later more about this but
let's just say that if this construction
is not efficient it's not due to Killian
it's due to the PCP itself okay so let's
put it in a different way the
cryptographic overheads over the
underlying information theoretic object
are really embarassingly small and
simple you're just doing some hashing on
top of some information 3d objects like
incredibly fast but at least as fast as
the underlying object and relief you did
an open research direction to construct
concretely efficient PCPs
but it's not Killians fault his
construction is beautiful and if we had
very good pc peas you know this thing
would run you know very fast yeah so
maybe you know and he not left the field
we would have gone back and fixed this
tiny issue as elegantly as function
family to be a universal why I cannot
think of it as probabilistic without
thinking too much about about a
parameter security parameter and stuff
like this why it's not simply
probabilistic so you're saying it's
suppose I take some you know pairwise
independent hash function like you know
carter-wegman style right the problem is
that in in those cases you what's
important is that you sample the hash
function after the data has been fixed
right but here the data is up to the
control of the torso
if the approver first sees the hash
function and then chooses you know how
to build the Merkle tree as a function
of it then it will be able to create
collisions because the carter-wegman
style construction says that he first
fix the data then you pick a hash
function and it says that over the
probability the hash function you know
collisions don't happen
but in fact for actual constructions of
potentially yes and in fact I should say
give more credit to Killian in a sense
that in his paper he not only laid out
this protocol but his goal was actually
to obtain efficient zero knowledge
arguments and intuitively the way he
achieves that is that the pearlescent
really couldn't stop here
instead there is an additional round
where the prover proves in zero
knowledge that this thing would have
accepted so and in particular you can
also use it for efficiency for example
you could try to continue and then you
know prove a new theorem about the disk
computation okay so let's try to analyze
this one I think there's something
interesting going on in the proof
security so we will prove that if some
if if some efficient
a Patil there convinces you wax so I'm
gonna use at this point there isn't
really no reason for me to make explicit
this instance AZT I will just call it X
okay convinces V of X with probability
Delta then exist some PCP I kill the
capital P tilde that convinces V sub PCP
with probability I hope I didn't mess up
the computations last night but you know
something like Delta minus negligible
and if I mess up something now I will
say that you know this is the main thing
they want to try to prove that if the
I'd there's some argument prover that
convinces the argument very far with
some probability okay then it is because
he is thinking of some PCP that makes
the very busy beaver far act excited
with some related probability okay okay
so this basically proves soundness right
because the soundness to the PCP might
say that there doesn't exist any PCP
that makes the verifier except you know
high enough probability so we are wrong
to assume that such an efficient PCP
exists h-his collision-resistant thank
you
yeah in fact let me just say it
explicitly we have used cryptography in
here because we're assuming there's a
collision oshkosh function this is
cryptography because you cannot achieve
this property against unbound approvers
because we are used I didn't make it
explicit by you know Merkle tree you
need to use a hash function that whose
output is shorter than the input and
necessarily collisions exist okay so we
have no chance to achieve this property
compressing hash functions against
unbounded adversary's okay and if you do
not achieve this property then you can
mess with the Merkle tree and cheat when
you reveal okay and basically conduct a
bit harder away you know attacks such as
the ones that were possible here without
the commitment
so yeah this lemma is assuming the hash
function is secure now what is
interesting about this lemma is the fact
that where are we going to find little
high tilde we are running prove a Patil
de right it convinces the very fire but
the prover is barely saying anything
like here it is he's running he's
convincing a very fire what do we see he
says a root then you know some
randomness and then you know five
answers and we're really to do I need to
somehow reduce to the security of the
PCP but for that I need to somehow
exhibit this enormous proof to satisfies
some property so in somewhere in a
security reaction I need to kind of
figure out what is the rest of the PCP
okay I can't just run the prover once
and kind of use it to kind of construct
a PCP I'm gonna have to run the prover
actually many times okay somehow I need
to extract a good PI tilde from the
provers head okay
is it clear there's something kind of
usually nontrivial that happens in 16th
arguments because there is some big
object that is supposed to leave in the
provers head but what you see it in an
appropriate solution is actually a tiny
sliver of it ok you have to kind of
recover the rest ok so so we need to
so-called extract I killed it from okay
and once you realize this is what you
want to do then kind of strategy is kind
of clear you are going to take your bite
yield there and you send it for now
we'll just say some age can be precise
about which 8h in a moment on this age
he will say some root here it is and now
basically we want to try to pause the
execution here and then consider all
possible continuations for many possible
continuations ok four possible choices
of randomness are ok so I'm going to say
R and here the answers in the paths
again for the same hash function he's
gonna say some route and then I'm going
to consider multiple possible
terminations of this a execution ok now
I'm gonna make a simple simplifying
assumption it's not really necessary I'm
going to assume that the total number of
possible random coins is actually polity
okay
doesn't have to be necessarily but if
you're careful you can make it so so for
now I'm gonna assume that in my security
reduction I can actually materialize all
possible random choices and I'm going to
gather all possible answers that
approval would say after saying this
route by the way why am i fixing the
same age what would happen if I change
my age he changes his route right so I
need to kind of fix a particular route
okay so this depends it depends on age
so I want to relate I'm gonna talk about
this in a moment okay but roughly
speaking you know if the prover
convinces me for BT Delta then there
must be you know some choice of age for
which the marginal probability convinces
me later across all ours is Delta right
so it cannot be that he convinces me
overall it will be T Delta and there is
no choice of age for which Delta
fraction of our leads to good things
right otherwise you're not about achieve
so we're gonna consider all possible
replies to whether we're gonna consider
the replies to all possible bars okay so
for any given age and route and I do
this procedure I have two outcomes
either once I consider all the possible
replies I find a collision somewhere or
I don't know all the options okay so
case one there's a collision somewhere
what does it mean they have a collision
somewhere it means that maybe there is
our and our prime for which there is the
same location of the proof that is
queried okay and then two values are two
different values are claimed right so
somewhere up on the path from the leaf
to the root it must be a collision
that's kind of a when you analyze the
collision resistance of no trees and
case two is that there are no collisions
now in the second case it means that I
can actually define it's well defined to
say that I have a pie tilde that depends
on H right because I can actually
complete Phi tilde okay there are some
locations are never query engine discard
the no collisions I can define a PCP
okay now let's consider what would
happen when I also take a probability
over each okay if there is a non
negligible probability over the
randomness of H that when I do this
procedure I find myself in case one then
I can break the collision resistance of
H okay so I am here I find myself here
only with probability that is negligible
okay so most of the time when I have an
age it will be the case that I can
define a PCP okay so here is like with
probability one minus negative now when
this happens this PCP has a certain
convincing probability for the PCP
verifier so I can define pi tilde that
convinces the PCP with probability say
epsilon of H it depends on H right
because it depends on a specific PCP
right and now I'm wondering hmm could it
be the case that this is always small
not really right because look I'm
assuming that over a whole probability
distribution of H and R P tilde
convinces vo acts with Ruby T Delta
right now up to a negligible through
choice of H you know I will be able to
define a PCP after that right and so it
must mean that there exists a choice of
H such that the probability epsilon of H
is at least Delta minus negligible right
they just by averaging okay so conclude
that there exists some H in H K such
that epsilon to the H is at least Delta
minus negligible because if there isn't
then there is no chance I will ever be
able to accumulate so much convincing
unity in aggregate okay that's it right
so this is my pie that I wanted to find
in fact there isn't just one age on
average say a dealt over to fraction of
choices of age will be such that epsilon
of H is at least say Delta where to -
negligible so in fact not only there is
one choice of H that provide produces a
good PCP most choices Oralia a good
fraction of HS produced a reasonable PCP
so this means I can actually efficiently
produce the specific myself how do I do
it I sample H myself and with
probability Delta over two
when I do this procedure I will usually
find a PCP the community and the size of
the space of H because you're using your
music H many many times I am using H
many times H is small
it is gonna be so first let's just be
clear when you build a miracle tree what
you care about is let's say it's two to
one or not to one venue to K 2 is in
English is written - 2 k space - space k
you know if house D is the output is
half the size of the input and you do
use it many times but sort of all these
H invocations are kind of folded into
case one in a sense that if I ever find
a collision okay then I shouldn't be
able to find a collision with high
enough for ability and if I don't find a
collision I'm fine because I can define
at PI tilde and I can talk about this
acceptance probability so awesome you
know when I say a collision somewhere in
this word here somewhere I'm hiding an
argument it basically says that I will
find one if I can't define a PI tilde
and this is the way you analyze the
collision resistance of a Merkel train
from the collision resistance of a hash
function at the moment you can if you if
you can lie about the leaf it is because
you found a collision somewhere in the
tree
not necessarily a very bottom but
somewhere this produces a convincingly
play for the all-0 strange convincing
what's random okay oh no i Polly be
properly Peter
the relief is random fights will be this
all 0 spin and hence the prover will
succeed in convincing it because for all
it's a just a box it does not produce
those your PCP or you can see the link
it has a good PCP for the very fire or
not but are you in that PCP system is
the all-0 PCP let me just very very
assumption that our fans apology space
precludes small sound etc you cannot
achieve you know 2 to the minus lambda
sound less error with such a small
number of random strings no I'm saying
that the total space of our is polity
but I cannot really expect that to be
the case if I want a small Sun etc I
need to kind of be a little bit more
careful about home right and doing this
proof so this is really a proof sketch
ok
and the reason why it's a proof sketch
is because I'm assuming that I can go
through all the random choices ok but
yeah but does that's in the Delta here
right so like for some that some hours
they will just not lead to good things
that's fine but the point is that there
must be a fraction of ours that do lead
to good PC we need to exit the very very
except because otherwise that won't
accumulate enough Delta here
imagine a hypothetical situation where
the verifier never worry the first
character or yeah then you drop it I
mean you can choose their bit Charlie
for example yeah yeah in general like
again so you can either fill it in like
it's kind of a if you never queried
there's a matter with recover a good
fraction of the PCP to be able to
recover the whole know you just fill it
in because like if you never queried
then it cannot affect this probability
right but there was a separate point
which is you know I think Akshay is
worrying about what happens you know on
if there is like you know specific
random strings on which something
strange happens I wanna say that you
know if you want the PCP to have
soundness error to to the minus lambda
okay you cannot also have randomness
complexity log T okay so this cut it
coexist okay so that's why right now I'm
doing a simplifying a proof where I'm
assuming that the bit complexity of our
is log T now if you wanna see a proof
that doesn't assume this don't go to
Killians
paper there's no proof of soundness
instead
a the argument that really shows this
very carefully is in a much later paper
it's a very beautiful through security
reduction in the universal arguments a
paperback and gold like it's actually
non-treated proof it's panzine or four
or five pages and it you know fixes it
kind of a deals with this issue and
deals with other things that basically
is a little proof where you don't really
have to touch all the RS essentially
what it does it says you can wrap patil
pi tilde into basically an Oracle that
gives the Oracle access to PI tilde and
for any query to PI till there has a sub
procedure to give you to either produce
a collision or give your answer that is
reasonable the section on trigger
and this is actually my point actually
so thank you for bring up these things
as strong as the intuition is for this
protocol properly proving it's secure is
I wouldn't say that easy okay
because you have to extract and general
extraction arguments or rather stop -
okay here you know the reason why this
is not quite the proof is because we are
assuming that I can see all the round on
this side okay and I think all this
confusion I think made my own confusion
but you know questions I think you know
under like my point which in yesterday's
construction yes but if you want to
drive the soundness error to be 2 to the
minus lambda you have to repeat the very
fire you know some number of times okay
and you can use yes you can use expander
efficient round on a simplification but
you will still have a lambda somewhere
right and you can't afford to go to the
lambda when you over all possible random
strings constant sound Sarah yes you can
get locti but if you want small sanest
error then you have to pay for lambda
somewhere in in the randomness
complexity then we have to I haven't
thought about this over a large off of
it
then we need to think of this proof in
the constant sound of Sarah regime which
might work I had I'm not gonna try to do
it Stan but I seem so but you know I you
would need to kind of light that sounds
convincing okay so the code just to come
make it explicit the proposal is as
follows consider a PCP with constant
Sarah Sarah where are indeed is log t
bits do this proof and then afterwards
do parallel repetition because this is a
public point argument and parlor
petition but it would be like it
slightly different construction right so
okay good questions and all of this is
pointing to the fact that you know when
you construct within the arguments
please prove them secure even very
simple ones require a proof so a key
needs protocol a motivates a number of
research directions many of which have
been sort of investigated in a line of
works one of them was already
highlighted before the break under what
cryptographic assumptions can we build
16 arguments so this shows that series
of slices yeah as was pointed out
earlier in later work shows is that MCR
H suffice as multi-collision resistance
and so more general you can just ask you
know what are the cryptography
foundations of successors and arguments
either from specific assumptions or
generic primitives
a-another direction is about efficiency
which was also brought up as a question
the construction itself is efficient but
PCB itself is we all know efficient PCB
constructions rather we know of
efficient asymptotically specific
instructions we can construct BCPs where
the state-of-the-art and PCP is is
actually pretty good the sympathetically
you can make this polity as a linear in
T which means T times some poly log T
you can also make the running time of
the prover a pretty close to the proof
size so this is like I think you know
like a really powerful statement that we
can construct we see peas that are you
know these fastest emphatically
unfortunately the number of poly logs
you know vlogs and after that is rather
a rather big and actually I've been
personally involved in trying to reduce
the number of logs and implement some of
these constructions and you know I can I
you know I can say from personal
experience that I do not think that our
current understanding of PCP is today it
leads to any concrete efficiency what
people have been trying to do instead is
to consider different models inspired by
PCP is that you know will be probably
discussed later in this program where
you can achieve even better some tactics
and more important more importantly and
also very very quite good efficiency
okay and you can sort of build on some
other ideas of construction such as such
as these I will not say much more about
it because today is a a mostly
introductory talk but let me say that
your understanding these foundations is
very useful to understand the state of
the art today last question that it
motivates is what about around
complexity this is a four message public
coin protocol
and now I would like to briefly motivate
the sort of stronger goal of achieving
non-interactive sixteenth arguments
today talking about how you get there
undecided what to delete here who votes
for this board it is the old best people
working for it different suggestion of
which board to go behind people are
concerned about the limit of this
executive decision this board goes
let's talk about mmm so-called synced
non-interactive arguments lots of things
called snarks a succinctly non
interactive and then arguments it's
better than snot right so hey so what
does it mean it means we would like to
have something that you know roughly
looks like this we have again the big
prove er that gets a Z T and W and now
instead of chit-chatting with the
verifier just says here's a very tiny is
a written down proof and as before the
verifier is tiny okay just the only
thing that changes that the interaction
consists of a single message from the
prover to the verifier now the first
realization when you entertain this goal
is that it's obviously impossible why
because because since we're discussing
arguments okay there are valid looking
proofs for false statements so if this
is what you're entertaining a malicious
poober could just show up and output a
valid looking proof for false statement
it could just have been been lucky and
it was born with it in its heart and you
can just up with I'm not gonna go into
that right now so before this was not
possible because look the first thing
the verifier does it just injects
randomness into the protocol okay so
here we're going to consider actually a
sort of standard cryptographic model
that circumvents these issues this is
the notion of a reference string okay so
what you do is you instead assume there
is some setup procedure that you can
think about it at system setup outputs a
reference string you can think about it
just some parameters for everybody that
are then used by the prover and the
verifier two respectively produce and
validate proofs okay and whatever useful
information the prover was born with it
will be defeated by the fact that then
the setup is run and the random string
is sampled the reference changes sample
so interactive so of course we could say
very far please run the setup and send
the reference string but what we want is
different string to sit up there to be
painted you know in fear moment right
and everybody looks at it and now
messages are just not interactive you
can always take the set up and ask the
verifier to do it but you will get
something to message this is a standard
model considering cryptography for
example a similar issue shows up when
you design non interactive zero
knowledge proof you need something in
the sky to help you because you know
it's proofs
even without succinctness just don't
exist so it's important to remember
every snark has a set up despite what
some people say so now why we care so
much about the interactivity well
there's some advantages why is you know
you can write it down or later use so
there's a question that when you
interact with the prover and very far
you can need to be both online and talk
to one another at the same time whereas
the you have no interactive proofs you
can really just write them down and
store them somewhere for example in a
blockchain or in a transaction or you
can send them over an email right and
then at a later time whoever cares about
it can look at it and perhaps you know
another very important realization is
that you kind of do the work once and
all others benefit
namely the prover that produced the
snark is done
anybody else can then check the proof so
in the interactive case if you want to
convince a lot of people you have to go
and talk individually which one of them
okay here you can just do this work once
yourself and you put it online okay and
then you can just look it up and check
it these two properties or in general an
interactivity are particularly suited
for blockchain settings where you know
one person makes the effort puts it you
know somewhere a transaction in the
blockchain and then the rest of the
network can sort of marvel at the proof
right without asking the prover to do
any additional work very proving things
is already hard work as these nevermind
if the prover has to keep doing it for
every person that is interested these
are just not gonna say much more about
it I think if it's not clear right now
it will become very clear like in a few
weeks when you know maybe you're exposed
to some applications that decidedly rely
on these but how let's say that this is
our new goal okay and we wanna a fulfil
this is goal and as always it's easier
to recycle what you already know or
rather than to start from scratch so
let's take what we have already built
this protocol and try to go from there
to here okay so the first observation is
that very no reason for the in every
interaction to resample hash function
okay as long as just the person sampling
hash function is not gonna do anything
like sketchy which we're not which it
won't because it is the setup we can
just ask the setup to do it for us okay
and everybody is using the same hash
function okay so we can sort of go to
three messages by asking
set up to sample H for all to use okay
let's progress but three still greater
than 1 so if do something else okay yeah
the next realization is that now H is in
the sky let's see what is the verifier
actually doing in interaction okay so if
now the first message is that the prover
sends the route and then the very fire
actually is not saying anything smart
he's just saying here's some randomness
right so you really need the very fire
to be there it's not that smart okay so
here we come across you know probably
you know the most beautiful and also
hard to understand analyze sort of
paradigms in cryptography which is
called the theater Shamir paradigm the
idea here is that we can replace the
verifier outputting randomness with just
some sufficiently strong cryptographic
hash function invoked on our tea okay so
let's kind of start to modify this
protocol and if I want to do it in place
absolute in place
you what we're gonna do is we're gonna
say introduce a new a character okay
it's gonna be a new type of hash
function I'm gonna give it a different
name because collision resistance is not
what you're looking for there'll be a
function f okay whose job is to be
applied to RT in order to derive our
okay for now just think about that's it
sha-256 okay that we need to say
something with smarter than that so we
need to analyze it in a moment but the
point being is that now this now we have
a setup that does two things it was
sample H so sample F for some family
that we talked about and then it will
kind of output those parameters for
everybody to use now if you notice
whatever the prover is doing here it's
all in his head there's no very fire
moving anywhere there so the final proof
that the verifier outputs so the program
outputs is going to be all the proper
messages so it's going to be our T first
to a message then PI sub q the answers
and paths so all of this is kind of in
all this is in the provers head and what
the outputs is this transcript okay
well the very fire does now is
the prior checks except that now the are
that it will choose is said to be F on
RT okay it says I'm going to derive the
randomness depending on the route now
the intuition here is that if the prover
in his head he is trying to get a lucky
random string that will let him cheat
what is he going to do well if F is like
strong enough to drive a cash function
the best thing you can do is to
basically invoke F on a bunch of
different artis okay but how many times
going to do it not many times is
basically analogous to thinking of many
different pcps and trying to run it
against a random string in each of those
cases okay or for the same PCP and you
can tweak a few locations and you try to
resample the randomness for it
but it's not I can actually choose the
randomness now all this is just
intuition is not anything formal about
it and in fact this type of construction
is very hard to understand but we'll be
able to analyze it at least in some
idealized resetting I would at least ask
first the question is syntactically good
what is going on here clear we are
realizing that the verifier was not
doing any much of anything new in the
protocol all we needed was for
randomness to show up at the right point
in the protocol and we do that by
plugging in a hash function to generate
it for us depending on the things that
should have come before okay this is
again like a very powerful and beautiful
year it's actually used in practice for
all kinds of other things and yeah it's
just really really cool idea so but now
we should want to try to say something
about this idea
so say just a little bit about it so let
me say what we can say about this idea
and then I was hoping to analyze it but
I think maybe I was a little bit too so
this is the previous proof doesn't apply
right now
so intuitively what we want is not quite
collision resistance we want the output
of F to be unpredictable or to be like
you know random looking a good way to
make it so is to let F be literally a
random function okay so we know whether
we can prove that if F is a random
function like literally a random
function then this works what does it
mean let me just at least write the
statement that you can prove not wait at
least suppose exist some efficient let's
call it P non-interactive a that makes
two queries 12 and convinces a
non-interactive max with probability
this Delta okay then there exist some
efficient until the interactive this is
for the say for example a three message
protocol that convinces interactive acts
with probability at least Delta R cube
and maybe some negligible somewhere so
this is basically saying we can relate
the security of the three message
protocol to the security of
non-interactive protocol when we have
plugged in F as a random function okay
so is the statement clear that there is
a loss by the way and this is inherent
okay anybody give me some intuition for
why this losses here
so we will not see why there's not much
true but we can certainly gain intuition
for why a cube must be there and I think
that's kind of a starting point for the
intuition of the proof so what can I
prove urdu that it cannot do during an
interaction do the interaction he sends
me the root and I have it it's in my
pocket right I send him they are and if
it hasn't like it tough luck
right so that's the are I'm sending
today but when he does this in his head
he can experiment you can say here's the
root with a PI F here's an R do I like
it or not listen I don't like it let me
try again okay if he can make upwards of
Q queries an F he can gain an advantage
a multiplicative advantage of Q over the
original soundness error because it's as
if he's playing that game against the
very father is willing to resend
randomness or to play that game in
upwards of Q times okay so there is a
loss it's here but you know in the
negligible setting of parameters Q is
going to be polynomial so if this is no
neglige if this is uh negligible this is
polynomial this is also gonna be non
negligible
now let's talk about the elephant in the
room in random functions are not
efficient okay so the size of a random
function is exponential okay and this
analysis relies on literally saying that
f is random now the study of how to
relax the property of being a random
function to more reasonable properties
that we could potentially instantiate
and concrete the complexity theoretic
assumptions is a rather subtle and
difficult endeavor in the sense that
their puzzle of positive and negative
results negative results that basically
say that in general you can't hope to if
you really rely on the food thing being
random you can't hope to Stan she ate it
but for their specific protocols where
you can actually prove the specific so
that's the protocols where you really
cannot instantiate it with anything okay
and so you're trying to play this game
in between we try to find natural
protocols and natural properties that
play game together to prove to obtain
approval security now a historically
actually this protocol was not analyzed
in this way a the idea of obtaining you
know can be first snark was actually due
to McCauley and his analysis and later
papers the followed suit so mccallion
valiant some Akalis 94 and Valentino 8
actually considered the setting where
both H and F are random okay if H and F
are random functions
then you can actually prove some a very
very nice
sound sadder then the sound sadder is
something like Q times the soundless
terror of the PCP plus some order q
squared over two to the K and it's not
this analysis is basically saying that
you know if you're not just relying on
collision resistance in the tree but you
let the tree also be some random
functions everywhere and you treat the
hash functions as ideal objects then you
can write down actually a pretty
explicit and nice expression that would
let you set for example security
parameters in practice and we're not
quite aware of and this is actually
tight this Q here is the same Q that you
see or here and so you know this
particular construction kind of seats
you can try to analyze it either like
this we're saying that the tree is your
H and then the function is random but
then there are negative results that say
that it's not so easy to make it not so
not not very random or you can say
everything is random looking and in
practice you'd actually do use
potentially not just as your H here but
you know shadows v6 everywhere okay and
then you are gonna me believe more that
the type of security you get is this one
so K is the output length H
so Asian f4 functions from to locate
okay and precisely these difficulties
have motivated people to study the
construction of a subsequent elective
arguments in completely different ways
and some of these we will see in a first
workshop that's basically you know if
you don't use BCPs but and you use other
objects related to PCPs
for example something called linear
interactive proofs you can try to bring
to bear other types of cryptography and
try to avoid using random functions that
in cryptography we called random
Oracle's nonetheless from a practical
perspective all of these constructions
are you know pretty solid in practice
and they bring to practice quite
different trade-offs in terms of proof
size proficiency and some of these will
be highlighted for example in the first
workshop yes for example if you were to
think of in the random Oracle model you
think of the setup as the choice of a
random function or in the real world you
can think about the initialization
vector for whatever general purpose
cryptographic hash function are you
you're using the main point that I want
you to take away today is that if you're
interested in how to instruct a 16th
argument or a 16th of interactive
argument it's actually not that
difficult once you assume the PCP
theorem away okay here is the picture of
PCP not complicated right here's a form
as such public-owned argument right and
here's how you collapse it to a
non-interactive argument it's a really
sort of a beautiful couple of
constructions and I think it should be
helpful to kind of keep them in your
head i reconstruction 16th arguments
that you might see that a new semester
might be less but that's fine because
they achieve other things even in
cryptographic assumptions or in
efficiency but this is a good starting
point to keep in mind yes so when you go
to practice
the sadness or issue becomes quite
relevant
so you said well approaches using
Burkholder but they use this error
correcting code which I assume
practically construction yeah so the way
I would use something like this in
practice I would actually instantiate
both H and F using a general purpose
hash function I would not go as far as
making H just a CH by design I would say
look H and F are both 556 and then you
look at this one and this is pretty good
like now in practice the Pacific will
begin the way but there are other
constructions that are sort of Killians
there are observe you can replace the
PCP with something called interactive
Oracle proofs we talked about faster and
then you get a similar behavior and then
analyzing the complete security loss of
black and gold like I think it's a yeah
interesting yeah you could still ask you
know what is the concrete security law
yeah I I really don't know which of
these options makes most sense in
practice in practice that would really
just stick with this the motivation to
try to understand that direction would
be to say well I have reasons for why I
really really want the H to be a CH and
not a general purpose function because
it makes my life easier in other ways
and then you would need to pick one of
these directions to try to understand
concrete security fully yeah usually the
previous paper by Poli - sure but but
first of all it will still all seven
over
[Music]
it's a great question somehow extraction
plays a role every time you prove even
soundness of a 16th argument because
it's and it's an unfortunate sort of
state of affairs because sometimes in
other parts of cryptography just proving
soundness as opposed supposed to prove
knowledge is a feature here it's you
can't gain a little bit for example in
the previous proof you know you can just
say there exists an H such that bar
blind you get a little bit this in the
tightness of a security reduction as
opposed to pick on random H and then see
what happens but I'm not aware of sort
of more fundamental I could not have
picked against it essentially because it
could have been one of the bad ones
which means that the previous proof was
still scheduled the theory must you
wrote the trick will use H and F being
dependent it it's not necessary but for
example it is convenient to do some
domain separation so you can either pick
the same random function and then kind
of fix the first it's convenient it's
nice it's convenient to think as
different random functions for the ones
that extract randomness for the Amir
style thing and a difference function
for building Merkle trees it is
convenient separately right so I think
lunch time I love to hear to answer more
questions but
[Applause]